hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we're gonna
zoom through this door I just opened and
there's spikes of death I'm guessing I
would what what what is this place
seriously why why is this important in
behind your ponics Bay of a ship I
really want to know because this makes
very little sense oh come on I see it I
could I could jump to that there we go
there - no oh man I'm so turned upside
down did I go through that door or do
they just come in there I have no idea
did I just come through there my an
idiot I'm anything I'm an idiot getting
so turned upside down right now normally
I'm good with navigation but when you
turn the world upside down ten million
times it gets kind of
all right still don't know where I'm
going because I think yeah my guide
point is telling you to go whoa
active
alright duly noted
okay don't go in there I probably do
have to go
oh hello security
hello thank god this is dr. cross hello
engineer Jacob temple I can't get
through to engineering support I know
there's a shipwide medical alert what
I'm trying to locate him
no we're safe for now but the tram is
down and we can't reach the escape pods
that attack
oh hello Naomi
yeah Oh me that was that another one or
was that the one I just shot would you
be the other gut just because I'm
running my cuts way too high on him
yeah now what whoa
Oh it opened the doors okay so I just
kind of run through
hello buddy sorry I'm just gonna excuse
me I didn't need to walk by here pardon
me friend
oh what's that foam rhyming crotch oh
hello buddy
what's that oh you don't look so good
one stick some bullet Oh whale
um drop anything
what are you
all right I guess
I guess I was supposed to come back here
kill that guy I think I need to kill
Hall
oh I see if our note box Oh
why don't I just to open the bus maggot
why do I get a smashing why do I have to
be so violent
Isaac crazy violent person I can't pick
up by this do I have like a moment give
me
I said I need to use it are we much
better
okay
and getting back to the machine gun is
who needs that brittle and wimpy pistol
that is like the pistol isn't it's like
the basic pistol except more useful
whatever I know okay now we're gonna do
something else kill more of those weird
greedy guys
you hear that
seriously if you guys hear that warning
ten kiloton math detective in food
storage
someone's singing a nursery rhyme
Wow hey hey get back oh you're gonna
start babies then letting anyone know
yeah
God y'all no no okay now where am I
going a backup okay I didn't need to go
that way
eventually I probably wouldn't needed to
go that way so that wasn't a waste of
time
all right where am I going I need to hit
up a store cuz I got I got like a ton of
stuff they did the store like right down
Wow
whoa you jerks trying to scare me I am
unscareable as my numerous other videos
have proven I can't be scared not even a
little bit
here
why are those even there why are they
spraying it nothing makes no sense okay
store or that was there a monster behind
me I didn't check oh look at all this
plasma energy I do not need that oh my
goodness contact energy I need to pull
around I know some of you wanted to see
the flamethrower in sari
haha maybe maybe later maybe I'll get it
probably would be very good for the
small guys probably very much okay
whole sound oh enough 800 right on the
money let's get some more nodes cuz why
not I can afford them I got the money I
got money who's in ow my ears and
they're not throwing another suit at me
so I can't fly back
hello there there was a bench right in
the second right you stopped by but it's
probably about time that I upgraded my
health that does something special all
right
oh the kinesin I guess I could upgrade
that but I'm hardly I've got some of you
have been saying that I need to upgrade
my stasis so I'll go with that
immigration and more energy and that
leaves me with two all right good
we're all good
and now we go on our way back to the
task of killing horribly mutated science
freaks I mean whatever this mutation
thing is it's like virus or alien
life-form or whatever it is the
recombinator it's it's very specific in
how it changes people which is weird why
why would it no why would it know
exactly what it could change a human
into or is it uh kind of beyond me I
don't know I'm not a bio biologist or
microbiologist I'm just a biomedical
engineer
[Music]
okay now where am I go where am i go
that am i go i am go that way yes go
I'll bring it on
hello don't trust Joe no trustee ah oh
yeah baby
but that problem please oh hello
whoa I didn't look at me from the side I
knew that the truck you know
all stop instantly yeah all right now
this but what's through here I want to
know want to know was that all I I
probably should have gone that way first
because that seemed like the much
shorter the two tasks credits did I miss
those I'm going down yeah okay I'm going
down yeah I really should have gone that
way first sorry about that but whatever
Tim deal it's all the same except oh god
I go down it's excruciating ly slow
elevator it's so slow it's that I don't
feeding system gimme I wanna feed some
animals
what that means more would this be
someone's job on the on the ship just
standing here and going oh you're
placing nutrient bath oh yeah oh you got
to be kidding me and now I'm going back
out I just wasted so much time just
trying to go back I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot alright actually I'm gonna
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching him when we come back I'll be
where I'm supposed to be so thank you
again and I will see you in the next
part bye-bye